[Music]
hey
vsauce michael here where is your mind
is it in your head i mean
that's where your brain is and your
brain helps you
remember and plan and make judgments and
solve
problems but you also remember and plan
with phones and notes and
calendars and you make judgments and
solve
problems with all sorts of things
you know when you think about it
the brain is really just a wet
lump of fat and protein no firmer than a
blob of tofu
but the mind is huge it's an ever
expanding organ of tissue and wood and
stone and steel
and people because of communication
communication allows us to even make
other people
extensions of our minds we can access
their memories
and perceptions and knowledge by simply
asking
or not i don't need to learn how to fix
a car
and practice medicine and vulcanize
rubber or
remember everything other people are
doing that for me
just as i do things for them we
are a species of individuals that is
also
one big interdependent lumbering growth
a frantic blur
of flesh and concrete a techno sapien
powered by imaginations and
passions made real by a hallowed faculty
we call reason reason it is said
guides us to truer knowledge and better
decisions
it's allowed us to increase life
expectancy suffer less
work together better and it's bound to
take us further and higher until the
end of time
or is it the organ we use to reason
takes millions of years to evolve but
the fruits of reason grow
rapidly and are ever accelerating over
the next
four decades we are expected to build
the equivalent of another new york city
every month and more concrete was
installed in the last two decades
outside the united states than the u.s
installed during the entire
20th century this growth means that
quality of life
around the world is rising it means that
electricity manufactured goods food
comfort and transportation are all
becoming
more common and accessible but there are
hints that reason and logic are
struggling against the complexity of it
all
against our growing dependence on the
things we've built
and their unintended consequences
nearly every part of life as we know it
today
involves or relies on a process that
releases molecules with lopsided
electrical charges
this property causes them to absorb and
re-emit thermal radiation pinging it
around so that it escapes into space
more slowly having more warmer parcels
of air
means stronger weather events they can't
be pinned to any particular
extreme storm but they make extreme
storms in general
more extreme and frequent what's at
stake isn't just bad weather it's
disaster
it's more lives lost more property lost
it's more droughts more hunger more
famine more people needing refuge
and an even greater reliance on the very
things that caused
the problem in the first place in total
we release about 51 billion tons of such
gases
every year and we need it to release
zero but how do you rethink
everything who gets to direct
the costs and trade-offs how do you
achieve
collaboration between nearly every local
and national government
when what works in one place won't work
everywhere
when decisions affect jobs in one place
and food in another
when not just things need to be
rethought but also
habits and traditions and values
how do you achieve consensus when a
problem
isn't obvious to the senses is far away
in space
and time requires solutions that affect
people in different ways
and as a product of science always
carries
some uncertainty the philosopher timothy
morton calls
something so massively distributed in
time and space
and so viscous so sticky that it adheres
to all that touch it
a hyper object every civilization that
grows at the speed of reason must at
some point
face hyper objects in fact
the fact that we still haven't found
evidence of intelligent life beyond
earth
has been brought up as evidence that
some sort of
great filter might exist that few
civilizations
manage to get past
that a hyper object like our impact on
the planet might be
such a great filter is not a new idea
what it might take to solve it
is the topic of bill gates's how to
avoid a climate disaster
and i decided to do this video in
partnership with him and his team
because the way we deal with hyper
objects reveals
a lot about the mind it's easy
and common to think that we would all be
better off if everyone was just more
rational right but what if reasoning
wasn't built for what we've become
let's begin by looking at behavioral
inertia
behavioral inertia is the tendency to
keep doing
what you're already doing status quo
bias it can be
a frustrating bias if you desire change
but its origin
isn't a flaw if an organism has managed
to survive long enough to reproduce
and provide and care for its offspring
then
the state of its world was sufficient
for its genes to spread that's
all it takes to persist the types of
organisms we see around
us will naturally be those that managed
to
persist and didn't after reaching that
point
rock the boat too much so behavioral
inertia can help slow down the
accumulation
of unintended consequences and the loss
of ideas that work
but it can also slow down innovation and
adaptation
[Music]
if the environmental impacts of our
society
were more immediate and unignorable
it wouldn't be so tempting to apply this
inertial break
but emissions are invisible
and their consequences aren't immediate
or local they
impact future people and people far away
those who are different from us poorer
than us people
we will never meet this may be one of
the first
challenges advancing civilizations face
wielding
not just the power of technology and
distributed cognition but also
the responsibilities extending the mind
is really cool but whether or not a
species can extend
their empathy might be a great filter
surely reasoning will allow us to do
that right
well what is reasoning well
reasoning is a way of making inferences
an inference is a piece of new
information extracted from the
information
you already have now we make inferences
all the time every living thing does
for example we don't have measuring tape
tentacles that shoot from our eyes and
what actually enters our brain
is just a 2d image but nonetheless our
brains can
infer depth by attending to cues like
stereopsis
occultation perspective parallax size
now when this happens we accept it as
reality we aren't aware of the visual
processing that made it possible
and we don't have to be if however we do
consciously consider why a certain
conclusion was reached
well then boom that's reasoning
reasoning is the process of making
inferences not automatically and
instinctively
but by looking at facts and seeing what
conclusions
they support when eratosthenes
calculated the circumference of the
earth to within a percentage or two of
the value accepted today
he didn't do it by measuring the earth
and he didn't just
perceive it as self-evident no he
inferred it from what he knew about
shadows and how long it took camels to
move
stories like that make it easy to
believe that reasoning evolved because
it supercharged our cognitive abilities
i mean it clearly moves us towards truer
conclusions
better decisions and knowledge no other
species could infer
attempts to describe the rules of good
orderly reason became logic in
mathematics concepts
so general and abstract that while we
were still animals
armed with them we were no longer beasts
but that's the rub isn't it if reasoning
is so great why are we the only species
with such
a sophisticated grasp of it and
if its purpose is truth and good
judgment
why don't we all agree on everything
it's tempting to think that
disagreements happen because well
i am being rational but those who
disagree with me are being irrational
if only people would just use logic and
reason what's happened to the world
well that's a fair complaint if you're
arguing over
logic puzzles but the world is not
a logic puzzle this however
is one paul is looking at mary
mary is looking at peter paul is married
peter
is unmarried is a married person
looking at an unmarried person yes
no or not enough information to decide
think about it the answer
is yes you may have thought there's no
way to know because we don't know if
mary
is married but look she either is or she
isn't
and if she is well then she a married
person
is looking at peter an unmarried person
if she
isn't then paul a married person
is looking at her an unmarried person so
no matter what mary's deal is the answer
will be
yes when people get this puzzle wrong
and the correct answer is explained to
them
they almost always immediately see why
it's right
and change their mind life
is not always like that let's take a
look
at a logical syllogism all elephants
are awesome michael is an elephant
therefore michael is awesome
the conclusion is logically valid it
follows from the assumptions
but are the assumptions true
no i am not an elephant
also this premise is subjective i mean
what does it
mean to be awesome can we measure it
with an oscemometer
so you can see why when analyzing
something like our impact on the planet
logic can only be a partial tool
if some people have more to lose than
others who gets to decide
which assumptions are fair still though
it would seem that reasoning should be
able to help here
if each of us would just attend only to
the facts
surely we'd all recognize the same
reasonable approach problem is
that's not how reasoning works since the
scientific study of human reasoning
began about 100 years ago
it has been found again and again that
not only are we
bad at reasoning lazy and biased but we
actually
seem almost programmed to be bad
like the flaws are intentional
in an episode of minefield i once used a
magician to pull off a little experiment
he asked people to look at two faces and
choose
which of the two they would prefer to
work with placing their preferences in
one pile
and those they rejected into another
then
the pile of people they picked were
shown again and each person was asked to
provide a reason
for why they chose that person but with
a little sleight of hand
the magician managed to sneak in some of
the faces they had just rejected
amazingly the majority of people didn't
even notice the trick
not only that they were able to
effortlessly explain
the reasons behind their choice a choice
they never actually made remembering
faces you've only seen briefly isn't
the easiest thing to do but other
studies have shown that even if the task
involves answering questions about one's
political beliefs
things we would seemingly have a firmer
grasp on nearly
half of participants will fail to notice
that the answers they gave have been
reversed
when they're later asked to explain them
point is we seem practically built
to give reasons for whatever we think we
must and not
the reasons we actually used to reach a
conclusion
what if we don't even use reasons to
reach conclusions well let's talk about
intuitions our brains have evolved over
millions of years to react to the world
around us in brilliant ways with little
to no input
from us for example when you notice that
someone is upset you don't consciously
think
hmm okay so uh well their eyebrows are
kind of
in that position and their speech seems
curt their posture is
these are all reasons to conclude that
they are upset
no instead the belief that they may be
upset was just
apparent you intuited it you know it
without exactly knowing
how you came to know it the
mood recognizing parts of your brain
operate in a way that is opaque
to your awareness but if someone asks
you
why do you think they're upset you can
nonetheless produce
all sorts of reasons some may have
actually been the ones your brain
attended to but they're all just guesses
instead of using reasoning to come to
conclusions
we use conclusions to come to reasons
now to be fair we can go the other way
we love puzzles
and when we don't have a strong
intuition either way we can sit down and
mull over various reasons to think
one thing or another our love of puzzles
suggests that reasoning has a survival
value organisms that found it
pleasurable
would be more likely to use it but when
we reason
alone even when we have no motivation to
reach any particular conclusion we still
exhibit deep biases that seem less like
mistakes
and more like features for example it's
been shown that between
two otherwise similar products people
will prefer to buy the one
with more functions even if they don't
want those functions never plan to use
them and think they're all pointless and
overly complicated
why well it might be that we find
such decisions easier to justify
to others we won't wind up being
potentially embarrassed when someone
asks why we didn't get the product with
more functions
well after decades of findings like this
hugo mercier and dan sperber began to
hypothesize
that reasoning didn't evolve to help us
make better decisions
but instead to help us be
social humans inhabit a cognitive niche
on this planet we aren't strong or sharp
or hidden or venomous
instead our advantage comes from
cognition
reasoning and cooperation we can plan
hunts
build traps and engage in coordinated
strategies that can be tested
and modified on the fly not by millennia
of evolution reason allows us to do
those
things it's hard to convince people that
your intuitions are true but if you can
give
reasons for them it's a whole heck of a
lot easier to convince people that
you're right
being able to argue over what the best
thing to do is is
vital when it comes to coordinating
action reasons also allow us to justify
ourselves in the eyes of others
to explain who we are and express the
kinds of reasons we like
what others can expect from us and what
we will likely expect
from them this social theory of
reasoning helps explain why two people
can
earnestly and rationally arrive at two
different views
they each have their own unique brain
and values and dispositions and
experiences
and those are what drove their thinking
the reasons they give
may or may not be the real reasons they
came to their conclusions but it's the
best
anyone can do the social theory also
explains why people
tend to give such weak reasons for their
beliefs at first
or when their intended audience doesn't
need much convincing
it would be a waste of time and
cognitive resources to construct grand
slam reasons for everything i
said and did and thought when it wasn't
necessary
instead i can offload some of that work
to other people
for example if i say i want to have
lunch at
abc burgers well my friend might respond
ah no thanks i had burgers yesterday and
i might reply back oh well that's no
problem
they also have hot dogs and great salads
but if my friend said nah no thanks i'm
trying to spend less money eating out
this month
i could reply oh well abc burgers
is really cheap and i've got a coupon
now what's going on here is that i'm
providing reasons
only as my friend presses for them if
they press harder and harder my reasons
will become better and better until
either i win them over
or we come to some different more
harmonious decision
so when people appear to be lazy
reasoners or
to have bad reasons or none at all it's
usually just the case
that they're using reason as it evolved
to function
socially it starts off weak improving if
others push it and always
tailoring its work to the intended
audience
the social theory of reasoning can even
explain the existence of biases that
otherwise
make little sense for example it would
seem that in coming to conclusions about
the world
it would behoove an organism to pay
particular attention to information that
went against what it believed
i mean that way they would be able to
adjust their beliefs making them
truer more general and more complete
to a certain extent that is what happens
but not always
when someone does their own research
they often come to the very conclusion
they want it in the first place this is
called
confirmation bias our tendency to look
for
prefer and interpret information so that
it confirms
what we already think it frustrates our
ability to accept new inconvenient data
and is a problem for the intellectualist
view of reason
if reason is for finding truth and
making
better decisions why would it have this
major weakness
well because the social theory says
reasoning
is a group activity let's say
that i think option a is true and the
best
and you think option b is true and the
well if we both researched both options
and sifted through reasons in support of
both options we would both have
twice the work to do than we would if
instead
i simply came up with reasons for why i
was right
and you attended the reasons for why you
were right
the confirmation bias at least halves
the cognitive work that must be done now
sometimes a lone reasoner
will have a bad idea or a decent idea
with some bad parts
the reasons they have to justify for and
argue for it
will be sufficient for them and those
who intuitively agree
but they may be weak however subjected
to deliberation
put forth into the machine of collective
thought it can be evaluated
and judged not by one mind or a group of
minds thinking alike but by something
very special the crowd
humans have long known of the wisdom of
the crowds
the phenomenon by which a collection of
many people
can process information into a
conclusion better than any one person
could do alone
it's why we don't trust big decisions to
a single person no matter
how educated or powerful they are
instead
we ask a group of people to deliberate
to reason together in this way the
biases and errors of each is smoothed
out
and the decision wiser in a famous
example it's been repeatedly shown that
if you ask a bunch of people to guess
how many jelly beans are in a jar
you'll find that the average of all
their answers
is closer to the real number than any
one
individual was alone what happens is
that although some people may guess a
number that is
like way too big that mistake is
balanced
out by the fact that others will
inevitably guess a number
that is way too small altogether
their disagreement evens out into
spectacular
accuracy we have now arrived
at the problem reasoning evolved to be
used
socially where many different
perspectives had to all deliberate
towards
a common conclusion such contexts are
becoming less
and less common and it is becoming
easier and easier to simply be
a lone reasoner justifying only a
particular viewpoint without doing the
harder work
of deliberating and acting the internet
gives voices to more perspectives than
ever before in our history
but it also makes it easy to disengage
from accountability
and to find places where everyone
believes what you do
furthermore because of technology we
confront more
issues more rapidly than ever before
that we are expected to have opinions
about
and the growing complexity and
specialization of the modern world
makes it difficult for each of us to
have well-informed prepared reasons
for the accelerating accretion of
intuitions we must form
in response we look for people who can
defend our intuitions
for us the reasons they give don't have
to be good
just good enough that we can feel like
justification exists
in the past unconvincing reasons
had to be painted on sandwich boards but
now
the democratization of communication
means that even
unpopular unconvincing nonsensical ideas
can be presented with the same trust
inducing typefaces and professional look
as common ones people can challenge the
weak reasons of others
show them to be contradictory and
produce better reasons for their side
but to what end it's all preparation for
a debate
that never comes we each play a very
small role in deciding how society is
run
even if a good faith discussion between
a representative slice of america came
to a resolution
if nothing can come of it why not just
throw shade and sick burns or revel in
the pleasure of reasoning by treating
everything like a big giant puzzle
it's easy to think that it doesn't
matter
because after all those in charge the
brilliant scientists
and powerful billionaires will surely
come to the rescue
some giant techno salvation is surely
on the horizon perhaps it is
but everything we know about reason
suggests that those
implementing it should be held
accountable by as many
different perspectives as possible
leaders could lead deliberations and be
elected for their ability to moderate
social reasoning
but that's boring why lead when you
could follow
look at what some people believe and
generate reasons for why they're right
and they'll love it of course the hard
work
the real work the work that truly
elevates us on this planet
is not in telling people that they're
right but in trying to convince
others and in doing so use reason
as it evolved to be used the future
of reason may in fact be the past
of reason in practice
what does all this look like well some
researchers have gone so far as to
recommend
national deliberation days where
citizens celebrate by literally joining
small groups
and talking through their opinions and
comparing
reasons tests of such strategies have
shown that a return to the small
targeted discussions our reasoning
abilities evolve to excel in
leaves all participants with a greater
understanding of not just what they
believe and why
but about decisions that could actually
be made
and actions that could be taken others
have gone even further recommending that
the future of reason at its best
is the construction of a latocracy
a form of government where decisions are
made
not by elected leaders but by people
literally chosen at random we decide the
fate of a person this way
why not the fate of the people what if
decisions were made
not by politicians alone but at least
occasionally
by groups of actual citizens
representing differences in
thought not just geography who were
brought together
and paid for their time to learn from
experts and then
deliberate on an assigned issue until a
conclusion was reached or
at the least a recommendation instead of
being motivated by
re-election money attention and power
individuals chosen at random
would have only their conscience to
guide them
special interests and corporations
wouldn't be able to cozy up to those
likely to be elected
because if any one of us could someday
serve
they'd have to cozy up to and protect
all of us instead of the learning and
deliberation
being done by people you will never meet
with offices and buildings you can't
access
gradually over time more and more of
your very own neighbors
would have had the honor people chosen
at random would obviously lack the same
celebrity status
and mandate that elected leaders
cultivate and achieve
and iconic figures we relate to aren't
bad
but our understanding of reasoning is
making it more and more clear that we
evolved
not to leave the thinking up to a few
great minds
but to the authority of the great mind
the lumbering organ of thought that is
everyone and everything
this is in fact how democracy first
worked lotteries were used to fill many
political positions in ancient athens
aristotle explained that the appointment
of magistrates by lot
is thought to be democratic and the
election of them
is oligarchic an oligarchy is government
by only a small
number of people look regardless of how
reason is brought back to its social
roots
if we can build more and better arenas
for deliberation
and use them to apply reason properly to
hyper objects like the impact
of our emissions on the planet we'll
have taught one heck of a lesson to
people
a hundred a thousand years in the future
i like to think that although widening
participation will be difficult
it might provide us with a kind of
existential security
the impact of emissions on our planet is
not going to be the last hyper object we
face
if we can do a good job with it maybe
far in the future when our civilization
has advanced to the point at which
i don't know people can be quantumly
recreated or something
they'll look back at our time and say
hey
let's bring them all back to life we
could use the cooperative abilities they
had then
ultimately the old saying that history
is the great teacher isn't a bad guide
we will all someday
be teachers ourselves because someday
we will all be history we will someday
be the ancients and we can choose
what that will mean and as always
thanks for watching
[Applause]
[Music]
you